sos médecins qui alerte sur sa possible
disparition les soixante trois
associations de médecins libéraux ont
annoncé un arrêt total de leurs
activités pour aujourd'hui jusqu'à
demain pour obtenir une augmentation de
leurs tarifs cécile 6 ou
alexandra et médecin aux urgences
médicales de paris normalement elle fait
des visites au domicile des patients
mais ce matin comme ses collègues des
sceaux et ce médecin elle fait grève et
sur les gros whatsapp du samu auquel
elle est inscrite ça s'affole ils
entendent être plus nombreux du coup au
samu pour prendre les appels que nous ne
pouvons pas régulé aujourd'hui quoi pour
ces visites à domicile alexandra et
payer 35 euros trop peu selon elle les
médecins traitants qui font
ponctuellement le même travail sont
beaucoup mieux payés au pour un patient
de plus de 70 ans qui a un sens pour
cent c'est à dire qu'ils en affection de
longue durée et qui est à son domicile
qui n'est pas hospitalisée un médecin
traitant s'il va le voir quatre fois
dans l'année il va pouvoir au lieu de 35
euros est payé 70 euros pour ces
consulte la tête trouvait alors isation
là on n'y a pas droit nous alors qu'on
est aussi médecin généraliste et donc
serveurs en france elles demandent une
revalorisation de ses consultations à
57,60 euros une revalorisation
nécessaire d'autant que le métier attire
de moins en moins les jeunes médecins
eux ce qu'ils aiment c'est travailler
dans des centres de santé où
tout est un petit peu clément et nous en
fait c'est un métier qui est
complètement différent travaillent nuit
et jour ce week end et jours fériés et
la semaine tout le temps en fait et on
se doit d'avoir une permanence de soins
constante donc on se répartit les gardes
et donc du coup niveau physique c'est
vrai que c'est assez difficile boudé par
les jeunes et peut valoriser
financièrement alexandre a craint que
dans quelques années plus aucun médecin
ne prennent la route pour rendre visite
aux patients et que son métier
disparaissent
le malaise des médecins généralistes
sont ils vraiment sous-payés voilà le
thème de notre débat d'actualité je vous
présente mes invités marie m'sick arason
bonjour bienvenue vous êtes médecin
généraliste à paris véronique guillotin
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes médecin
c'est la triste de meurthe-et-moselle
vice présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales au sénat frairie
bizarre bienvenue soit vous êtes
économiste de la santé avec nous en
visioconférence jean christophe maes
roncq et président de sos médecins
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous et je
présente aussi évidemment matthieu
croissandeau
éditorialistes
deux sens public présent à mes côtés
tous les lundis et tous les mercredis
bonsoir mathieu je commence avec vous
jean christophe mas seront peut-être
faire un bilan de la journée vous n'avez
pas travailler aujourd'hui est ce que
vous savez combien de vos collègues de
sos médecins étaient dans le même cas
ah oui oui c'est une mobilisation
nationale c'est un 100% ce soir pour les
structures sos médecins 1300 médecins à
l'arrêt depuis ce matin 8 heures jusqu'à
demain matin 8h donc là c'est un
mouvement qui est totalement suivi qui a
rencontré un un succès important avec un
un bon ressenti de l'opinion publique je
crois et je pense que les messages sont
sont passés alors il faudra peut-être
revenir sur ce que
l on a perdu le set apporter quelques
précisions oui alors j'ai pas entendu la
fin de votre phrase mais vous inquiétez
pas on a du temps pour apporter des des
précisions peut-être pour commencer
toujours avec vous dr may seront pas de
revalorisation de l'indemnité de
déplacement depuis quinze ans est-ce que
c'est là dessus c'est de moins en moins
rentable en quelque sorte où sera de
moins en moins d'intérêt tout simplement
d'être médecins sos
oui en tout cas là la visite à domicile
n'a pas été revalorisé depuis 15 ans
c'est surtout un acte
complexe chronophage une visite à
domicile ça prend trois quarts d'heure
une heure
35 euros en journée voilà c'est ont fait
trois consultations dans le même temps
au cabinet donc c'est c'est quelque
chose que l'on fait part par conviction
parce qu'on sait que ça apporte un
service aux patients important est que
s'il n'y a pas de meilleure alternative
dans bon nombre de situations mais c'est
clairement pas rentable on est pas du
tout là en train de vouloir défendre un
acte rentable on est là en train de
vouloir défendre un service rendu au
patient marine sic les rasions est ce
que est ce que c'est la même chose pour
vous êtes pas sos médecins vous êtes
médecin généraliste vous vous faites des
visites à domicile
encore aujourd'hui ou pris finalement de
moins en moins on en fait de moins en
moins je fais partie déjà d'une
génération qui faisait nettement moins
qu'à génération d'avant et je vois dans
les internes que jean cas notamment à
mon cabinet qui a plus du tout de
l'affection pour pour ce type d'exercice
c'est vrai que à paris en plus c'est
vraiment extrêmement difficile c'est
comme disait mon collègue extrêmement
chronophage alors qu'on a déjà une
charge importante de notre activité dans
nos cabinets donc c'est très difficile
de dégager du temps pour ces visites et
qui sont pourtant extrêmement importante
mais est ce qu'il ya des visites mieux
rémunérés parce qu'effectivement 35
euros pour une visite à domicile on this
est un peu enfin voilà peut comprendre
la la la la la colère et le malaise des
médecins mais est ce que certaines vite
moi j'ai lu qu'il y avait des visites
l'ong qui a été rémunérée 70 euros de
quoi on parle certains critères
effectivement qui permet de tarifs et un
peu différemment la visite mais ça reste
des cas qui sont assez exceptionnelles
entre autres activités il faut se dire
que un patient âgé qui au domicile
souvent il faut aller le voir une fois
par mois nous nos passions chez quelques
patients comme ça que je vois à domicile
et il ya vraiment besoin de suivre
l'évolution des pansements devoir de
coordonner l'infirmière le kiné donc
c'est un vrai travail d'équipé c'est un
autre travail que celui qu'on peut faire
en consultation ça prend du temps c'est
une vraie expertise et pour autant c'est
très souvent rémunérés 35 euros ce qui
dans paris est loin d'être réaliste et
je pense dans plein de régions en france
aussi passé beaucoup de grandes villes
aussi il ya aussi des
zone où les déplacements peuvent être de
très longues distances donc c'est vrai
que ça devient complètement aberrant
salé blizzard vient d'où cette cette
aberration l'a décrite par deux
représentants finalement différents des
médecins généralistes comment elle
s'explique mal s'explique par les
politiques de santé depuis une vingtaine
d'années - qui fait qu'on a si un modèle
de santé qui datent de 45 et notamment
aussi qu'ils étaient complétées en 58
par une horde des ordonnances très
importante debré qui a fait de l'hôpital
le carrefour du de la gouvernance du
système de santé aussi bien pour les
soins pour l'enseignement que pour la
recherche c'est à peu près toujours le
cas aujourd'hui on l'a vu avec la crise
le coc vide de la santé avec la cegos
quête à ségur de l'hôpital
la crise allait généraliser à
l'ambulatoire médico-social à l'hôpital
pour une rave pour plusieurs raisons
mais notamment une raison c'est qu'on a
inversé la hiérarchie des valeurs dans
le système de santé ce qui est tout en
haut de la hiérarchie des valeurs sont
les hommes sont les femmes c'est un sens
les ressources humaines y'a pas à ce
sens des ressources humaines de qualité
et ce qui fait la force qui a fait la
force au xxème siècle qu'est ce qui fait
encore la force malgré un système qui
est en bout de souffle ça reste ses
ressources humaines en santé qui sont
parmi les meilleurs au monde
sait que depuis vingt ans je demande on
a fait de cette ressource humaine un peu
la variable d'ajustement des budgets
puisque on a une approche qui est
comptable il faut rentrer dans un budget
qui est votée au parlement le projet de
loi devient son on a rogné sur deux
choses l'innovation et les la
rémunération que ce soit dans le prime
public comme dans le privé
vingt ans après donc on a gelé 'l'indice
à l'hôpital pendant 10 ans on l'imaginé
pendant différents thèmes attend et on
n'a pas revalorisés depuis 15 ans les
visites à domicile mais regardez la
consultation de loin la plus importante
que la consultation chez le médecin
généraliste dans son cabinet 25 euros
c'est à dire vous avez 50 % de charge
dans un cabinet en moyenne c'est à dire
quand vous allez chez votre médecin il
lui reste dans la poche 12 à 13 euros
mais c'est quoi ces l'écoutent qui est
pas rémunéré sinon c'est l'humain ses
définitions finances à l'acte en reste
les flancs seront à l'acte non
franchement elle a comme ça c'est les
modalités de paiement quand vous exercer
en libéral vous avez historiquement
principalement
un mode de paiement à l'acte c'est à
dire que à chaque acte est rémunéré
valoriser vous avez une consultation
vous avez une grippe à une consommation
c'est 25 euros bon ça c'est le mode de
paiement à l'acte c'est le meilleur mode
de paiement pour les soins courants en
revanche est totalement inadapté à deux
missions qui n'ont pas été suffisamment
confier aux médecins généralistes soient
les missions de prévention ça c'est un
forfait faut donner parents forfaits en
fonction de mission et puis les missions
de coordination pour les la prise en
charge des patients chroniques et ses
deux tiers des dépenses des patients
chroniques des deux tiers des dépenses
d'assurance maladie sont portés par les
patients chroniques donc vous pouvez
faire faire des économies considérables
aux systèmes s'ils vous valorisez si
vous rémunérer le médecin traitant pour
cette prise en charge ce qui n'est pas
fait donc à chaque fois c'est une c'est
un marchandage de tapis parce que c'est
incompréhensible il faut voir que la
discussion nous on veut 56 euros qui est
parfaitement légitime mais vu de
l'extérieur des patients seulement mais
ils font l'aumône ont fait l'aumône faut
savoir que ça augmente de 1 2,3 euros
tous les cinq ans la chaude donc voyez
qu'il faut sortir de cette logique là
par une refonte systémique on va
proposer bientôt à l'institut santé fait
trois ans qu'on travaille dessus c'est
pas simple mais il faut complètement
repenser le modèle véronique guillotin
je rappelle que vous êtes que vous êtes
médecin repenser complètement le modèle
vient de dire frairie bizarre est ce que
est ce que vous vous y préparer moi je
pense que le monde a complètement changé
vraiment on est sur un point de bascule
et il faut absolument effectivement
repenser le modèle dans son ensemble on
travaille aujourd'hui pour moi je suis
encore d'une génération au dessus de la
vôtre où j'avais mon cabinet je faisais
mes consumer visite parce qu'on faisait
ça jour et nuit voilà aujourd'hui
j'étais disponible pour presque 7 jours
sur 7
enlevé entre a et le matin enfin voilà
aujourd'hui on a une nouvelle génération
et je pense que c'est une bonne chose
qui ne veut plus travailler comme ça
c'est une génération qui travaillent en
pluridisciplinarité et je pense que
c'est très bien pour les patients parce
que quand on allait faire une visite à
domicile et tout le monde le dit c'est
hyper chronophage en passe d il faut
sonner faux enfin on voit les personnes
âgées elles descendent on ouvre on
s'assoit enfin voilà sont des
consultations qui prennent excessivement
de temps donc oui la consultation n'est
pas suffisamment payés mais au delà de
ça c'est tout un système qu'il faut
revoir je veux dire on ne peut pas être
payés à l'acte parce que déjà c'est un
effet pervers on va voir alors
aujourd'hui l'acte technique par contre
est bien rémunéré donc on voit les
médecins s'orienter ou des parents
certaines cliniques ou regroupements
s'orienter plutôt vers de la technique
qui lui est rémunérateur et donc la
vidéo pour le grand public s'avère
plutôt des médecins spécialistes il à
l'acte la l'échographie et la
radiographie fin des actes techniques où
on fait de l'écho aux de l'endoscopie
fin des choses comme ça aujourd'hui
l'acte intellectuelle que ce soit chez
le médecin généraliste sos médecins ou
même en hôpital par exemple les
internistes aujourd'hui cette spécialité
qui est hautement intellectuel et qui a
une valeur humaine importante n'est
absolument pas rémunéré à sa juste
valeur donc on a ce problème là et on a
un problème en fait de refonte globale
désertification médicale comment doivent
travailler les médecins mais également
les paramédicaux avec les médecins
chacun doit retrouver de la place dans
ce système là et il faut à mon avis de
bousculer les choses de manière plus
importante parce qu'on n'y arrivera pas
c'est pas des augmentations
même s'il le faut à court terme mais ce
ne sera pas par des augmentations
segmentaire comme ça qu'on y arrivera il
ya tout le volet de la prévention gens
je n'ouvre pas mais qui est
un maître aussi d'en faire un focus sur
les déserts médicaux si c'est ça pourra
pocket on va voir alimenté le malaise
général on va voir comment on commence
ça se prépare comment vous percevez ce
débat mathieu la
cette question du la rémunération des
médecins et peut-être de leur image dans
l'opinion c'est intéressant de voir est
ce qu'il ya un décalage comme une
formidable de l'hypocrisie de la part
des pouvoirs publics notamment sur le
rôle du médecin généraliste qu'on
considère ces rixes et le notre système
de santé est construit autour et
pourrait par l'hôpital mais la cheville
ouvrière de la médecine de proximité ça
reste le généraliste alors tout le monde
encense les généralistes on veut les
mobiliser quand il s'agit de vacciner
les gens ont dit c'est des relais
d'opinion s'est déroulée de prévention
et en même temps c'est vrai que c'est
les parents pauvres c'est le parent
pauvre de cette médecine libérale alors
il ya des syndicats de médecins
généralistes ils ont cédé un seul au
cutter ils ont ils dans leur entrée au
ministère la santé mais il n'y a pas non
plus les grands pontes qui en doutent
discipline et il n'y a pas à
7,6 juste cette supériorité j'allais
dire en tout cas vécu dans le milieu par
les spécialistes
il n'y a pas que l'on regardé le tarif
des le tarif des consultations c'est pas
la même on considère encore que les
généralistes sont à la fois des
chevilles ouvrières mais payés comme des
ouvriers de la médecine si je suis si
j'ose dire et du coup ça pose un vrai
problème est alors pour après pour la
désertification médicale on y viendra
mais c'est c'est un vrai vrai problème
pour les élus locaux pourra pour attirer
les médecins et là pour le coup c'est un
sujet qu'elle jamais vraiment été mis
sur la table ce qu'il faut les payer
mieux ce qu'il faut les forcer à y aller
dans leur première année est-ce qu'il
faut les aider conventionnés soit ceux
qui vont à lyon
dans un instant mais cette histoire des
mandats sera émise à kessoua pensée est
ce que finalement les médecins
généralistes manque de deux relais un
peu comme ça avec cette stature du chef
de clinique du chef de service parfois
si on revient à 58,58 a construit ce
mandarinat à partir de l'hôpital public
en faisant des chefs de service
véritablement les grands les grands
manitous du système et d'ailleurs c'est
pour mettre fin à ce système qu'on a et
attiser le système ce qu'il faut voir
que ce qu'on a fait depuis vingt ans et
en fait transférer tout le pouvoir qui
était notamment dans les mains de ces
mandarins et aussi dans les mains de la
relation du médecin patient c'était la
force de notre système c'est la
décentralisation de la gestion des
ressources à l'échelle vraiment du
terrain avec des médecins libéraux des
paramédicaux libéraux qui étaient
relativement libre on est le système de
santé qui offre le qui a offert le plus
d'autonomie et de liberté aux soignants
comeau soigner ça c'est la force et puis
tout d'un coup on s'est dit ça ça va
plus parce qu'on ne maîtrisait plus
assez les dépenses et on a fait
l'analyse fin des années 90 que la
raison c'était parce qu'il y avait trop
de liberté trop d'autonomie avait une
gabegie donc il fallait que l'état
reprenne par damas reprenne la main non
mais non c'est non c'est tout et ça a
été une erreur évidemment 3d a buté en
tenant tous m il ya des abus mais plus
vous décentraliser la gestion des
ressources en santé plus vous êtes
efficient plus moules à centraliser plus
vous développez et c'est exactement ce
qui s'est passé une forme de perte de
reconnaissance de ceux qui sont sur le
terrain une explosion de la bureaucratie
parce qu'aujourd'hui tout est décidé y
compris dans ou là vous allez vous
installer à ségur s'ils voulaient donc
dans ce monde d'aujourd'hui qui a
complètement changé c urs et de l'avenue
du ministère
celui-ci est donc il faut en fait faire
marcher relire ou réinventer le modèle à
partir des territoires on va en dire
deux mots c'est cette territorialisation
qui sera piloté par les acteurs donc que
vous responsabiliser y compris pour
qu'ils aient suffisamment de soignants
sur le terrain et sur le mandarinat on a
été beaucoup trop loin parce que là
c'est sûr qu'on a cassé ce mandarinat
bon on a cassé tout pouvoir y compris
des chefs de service que vous avez cette
crise de reconnaissance aussi à
l'hôpital le chef de service ne décide
plus de rien oui à ses lecteurs qu'un
ministre at oui sauf que le directeur
aussi il dépend directement du ministère
de la rs qui dépend du ministère oui en
fait c'est qu'on n'a pas décentralisé on
a déconcentré donc on à recentraliser
hockey alors je voudrais simplement vous
donner quelques chiffres comparatifs
européen sur la rémunération des
médecins généralistes on a comparé le le
la rémunération des médecins au salaire
médian dans dans chaque pays quatre
exemples allemagne grande bretagne
france pays bas on voit que on est loin
de l'allemagne et 2 est relativement
loin de la grande bretagne un peu devant
les pays bas je reviens vers vous
jean-christophe masseron est ce que
justement sur cette idée de comparatif
est ce qui est un système similaire par
exemple en allemagne et est ce que vos
collègues allemands sont mieux rémunérés
que vous pour les visites à domicile
alors la question des visites à domicile
dans nos pays voisins c'est quand même
quelque chose qui n'a pas vraiment
d'équivalent il ya des pays qui
pratiquent la visite à domicile dans les
pays scandinaves me semble-t-il il ya de
la visite à domicile mais c'est quand
même une spécificité française
qu'on essaye de défendre là après on
peut on peut débattre de son intérêt et
nous on attend des pouvoirs publics
aussi qu'ils puissent affirmer l'intérêt
de la de la visite à domicile mais je ne
crois pas que l'on puisse s'appuyer sur
l'expérience de nos voisins européens
pour pour dire que la france est en
train de perdre de vue là la visite je
reconnais que la visite étant un
privilège
français mais je crois qu'on a tous les
arguments pour le pour la défendre et on
va continuer évidemment d'en parler je
reviens vers vous tout à leur joie qu'on
parle des déserts médicaux parce que
c'est c'est scellier puis çà çà çà
s'imbrique dans cette question du
malaise des des médecins généralistes
écoutez ce que ce qu'on disait le
premier ministre jean castex qu'il était
face aux aux maires ruraux c'est la
semaine dernière le 24 septembre
quand j'écoute partout je me déplace
parfois le désarroi
des maires ruraux s'est traduit celui
des populations j'ai l'impression de
revivre tout ce que j'ai vécu
croyez le bien
les difficultés le voir partir un vieux
médecin généraliste qui ne comptait pas
ses heures à la retraite pour ne pas à
retrouver ou parfois en retrouver un qui
travaille un peu moins parce que plus
jeune le combat de titans pour faire une
maison de santé il vient d'où ce
problème il y a quand même de 45 ans ou
50 ans de politique malthusienne le
numerus clausus appelons un chat un chat
[Applaudissements]
qui ça c'est du concret
alors sur cette question des déserts
médicaux marion vidéo nous a rejoints
bonsoir marion vient venu effectivement
il ya pas mal d'appels pour pour trouver
une solution et ses appels ils viennent
souvent des élus des élus ruraux qui
s'alarme de la désertification médicale
dans les campagnes et des inégalités
d'accès aux soins qui se creuse en
france avec des phénomènes de surdensité
dans les métropoles et de sous dotation
dans les zones rurales mais également
dans les villes moyennes pas plus tard
que ce week-end lors du congrès de
l'association des maires ruraux de
france les élus ont donc au bout demandé
au gouvernement d'agir de façon plus
coercitive sur le corps médical et parmi
elles les mesures que certains réclament
il y à l'obligation pour les médecins en
fin d'études de venir travailler six
mois à un an en campagne passée de
l'incitation à l'obligation c'est aussi
ce que défend le sénateur philippe
folliot qui a déposé en juin dernier une
proposition de loi le centriste du tarn
c'est le constat suivant les incitations
de l'état aide financière matérielle
exonérations fiscales donc que peu de
résultats sur l'installation des
médecins en campagne et puis les
professionnels de santé eux-mêmes ne
sont pas enclins à contribuer au
rééquilibrage de la démographie médicale
il cite ce sondage qui avait été
commandée en 2007 par le conseil
national de l'ordre des médecins qui
révèle que 63 % des étudiants et 60% des
jeunes médecins n'envisage pas de
s'installer en zone rurale en raison de
leur isolement pour lui il faut donc
changer de système et mettre fin à la
liberté d'installation donc on parle
d'une contrainte ça pourrait prendre
quelle forme alors l'idée serait
d'appliquer aux médecins ce qu'on impose
aux pharmaciens par exemple lorsque vous
voulez ouvrir une officine il faut que
vous ayez l'accord de la rs et que vous
répondiez un numerus clausus c'est à
dire un nombre d'habitants recensés dans
la commune où cette pharmacie va être
installé et je vous propose d'écouter
justement un sujet le sénateur philippe
folliot sur le territoire national
aujourd'hui il y à des pharmacies
partout et elles sont très équitablement
réparties sur le territoire national
à l'instar de ce qui se passe pour les
médecins l'objet de cette proposition de
loi un calque et le mode d'installation
des médecins sur celui des pharmaciens
avec un système de licences quand il y a
trop de médecins sur un secteur eh bien
ils ne pourront plus installer librement
voilà et ils devront atteindre comme
médecins partent à la retraite ou ou
décident d'aller exercer ailleurs pour
pouvoir s'installer sur ce territoire
alors le sénateur admet que c'est un
système plutôt dirigiste mais c'est
aussi pour lui le plus efficace pour
répondre au problème il me dit également
pour des stages obligatoires en milieu
rural pour casser notamment les préjugés
des jeunes médecins pour les élus cette
problématique est en tout cas un enjeu
de santé publique et des chiffres le
prouvent ce week-end l'association des
maires ruraux de france a présenté son
étude sur la santé en milieu rural on y
apprend que depuis les années 2000
l'espérance de vie se dégrade en
campagne les hommes euro vivent ainsi
deux ans de moins que les urbains il y a
trente ans c'était car était seulement
de trois mois merci marion marion mieux
pour cette chronique ce zoom sur la
question de la désertification
est-ce qu'il faut un système plus
coercitif on va répondre ensemble à
cette question je commence à une
véronique billot temps puisque c'est à
nos collègues sénateurs qui qui fait ses
propositions ouais moi j'y suis pas
favorable alors j'y suis pas favorable
parce que je pense que c'est prendre
c'est prendre le boul du problème et il
met une coercition je porte dans l'or on
a des médecins dire que les médecins on
l'entend ont fait 12 années pays au
service de l'état il faut qu'ils
rentrent derrière déjà je pense un
médecin et médecins au 6e année de
médecine ensuite entre la sixième et la
dixième voire 11e année ils sont quand
même dans le système universitaire et je
crois que c'est à ce moment là que les
stages doivent être pas hospital au
centre est mais que ces jeunes médecins
doivent être doivent réaliser leur stage
à l'hôpital certes pour garder la teneur
universitaire mais doivent aussi aller
découvrir des stages en territoire euros
ils ont jusqu'à la dixième année ils ont
un tison quand ils sortent et qui sont
docteurs en médecine ils ont 30
32 des x 33 ans souvent une famille
enfin voila moi je crois qu'il faut à ce
moment là ils ont eu dix années c'est au
système en fait à travailler sur la 5e à
la 10e année pour pouvoir leur faire
découvrir le milieu rural si on les met
en milieu rural dans des cabinets isolé
dans laquelle ils veulent plus
travailler ils ne reviendront jamais et
si vous les oblige à rester deux ans
dans un cabinet pour remplacer un
médecin qui est toujours isolée au fin
fond de sa campagne ils n'y resteront
pas donc aujourd'hui il faut réaménager
la manière de travailler de ses médecins
moi je suis très d'accord pour dire que
pour l'instant ça fonctionne pas sur le
plat on vit le sénateur folio
l'incitation ne suffit pas on n'a qu'à
ma numerus clausus qui a quand même été
plombé pendant pendant plusieurs années
on va remettre des médecins en plus sur
le circuit donc on devrait avoir un
appel d'air b si les conditions
d'installation de ce fonctionne pas ou
ne le voulaient refuge vous n'arriverez
pas aller à les fidéliser ses médecins
là ils vont partir à l'hôpital ils vont
faire médecin coordonnateur dans les
zones frontalières ils vont partir dans
les pays à côté parce que déjà c'est
mieux payés et puis voit donc je pense
qu'il faut plutôt se poser la question
de savoir comment on peut retravailler
sur ces zones sous denses aujourd'hui
qui ne sont d'ailleurs pas que des zones
rurales c'est une erreur de dire que la
ruralité seul sou
certification médicale il ya des dix ans
et métropole on est des quartiers
entiers aujourd'hui on a quand même
toulouse c'est une saison magnifique
donc il faut pas qu'il faut pas cliver
la ruralité pas la ruralité moi je pense
qu'il faut c'est encore une fois une
transformation du système sert permettre
à ces jeunes médecins d'avoir de leur
redonner envie de travailler là où ils
sont et il ya des systèmes de
coopération alors moi je suis assez
favorable aux mesures qui ont été prises
les maisons de santé l'essai pts sont
des primaires les des communautés
médicales alors communautés
professionnelles et territoriales risque
et les pneus santé je sais du radium et
la seule difficulté de ces systèmes là
c'est que c'est très enfin on bouffe du
temps de techno voilà c'est chronophage
sur la la technocratie enfin on ferait
plutôt mettre les mains les jeunes ayant
sur le terrain qu'au cas d'école on vous
aurait obligé à vous installer dans un
désert médical
aux sorties de chais pas dix ans dix ans
d'études venu fait que je trouve ça dur
moi d'imposer sa je pense que y'a déjà
pas enfin de moins en moins d'attrait à
être médecins il ya moins de
reconnaissance qu'avant il ya moins de
prestige social et intellectuel à être
médecins surtout ou généraliste même
s'il ya un travail au niveau
universitaire sur la médecine générale
mais quand même dans l'opinion publique
c'est pas forcément quelque chose de
très prestigieux il faut effectivement
se dire comme a dit ma collègue que
quand on arrive en fin d'études la
profession s'est aussi beaucoup
féminisée donc les les médecins qui
sortent
diplômés ils ont une petite trentaine
d'années on va dire c'est le moment où
il ya une vie de famille etc et donc les
faire se délocaliser je trouve ça
vraiment dur
et je trouve que c'est c'est encore
faire porter la charge à des gens qui ne
sont pas responsables de la situation
donc ça ne me paraît pas être une bonne
chose la coercition je trouve de toutes
façons que ce n'est pas un système qui
porte ses fruits de mer général question
pensez vous avez luisa gens pensent
qu'on peut y échapper aux messieurs
j'ai tenté avec beaucoup de mythes et
d'expliquer depuis vingt ans pourquoi
cette reprise en main par l'état s'être
bureaucratisation pensant qu'on allait
enfin maîtriser les dépenses parce qu'on
a les maîtriser l'activité des
professionnels de santé qui a juste eu
l'effet inverse ce qui était déjà sept
manque de reconnaissance voyez un
praticien sur le terrain qui vous dit
mais déjà qu'on se sent pas très reconnu
chargeons là les politiques qui vous
disent bon c'est vrai qu'on a peut-être
un peu faute et pendant 40 ans parce
qu'on a diminué par deux numéros ce que
le doute chez les médecins a enchaîné
dentiste chez les pharmaciens il n'y a
pas de pénurie ce qu'elle ait une
différence qui serait gelé mois mais
c'est d'une misère intellectuelle de
proposer ce genre de choses évidemment
vous allez finir de tuer le système si
vous faites ça parce que avec la
coercition je rappelle que la
désertification médicale elle a démarré
à l'hôpital où il ya un bail après 30 %
de poste vacant chez les praticiens
hospitaliers 30% un presque un sur trois
elle a ensuité été dans les ehpad où on
ne trouve plus de soignants il ya plus
de médecins dans les abeilles n'y a même
pas un médecin par ehpad pour 90
résidents et maintenant elle arrive en
effet en ville enfin
ok donc c'est pas la solution c'est la
refonte systémique qui passe par une
approche par plusieurs choses mais
d'abord une approche territoriale ou
venez on va vraiment la territoriale et
sans le même territoire pour tous
pourquoi parce qu'il faut passer du soir
se défend une approche globale il faut
aller donc le la qualité de vie des gens
la santé c'est pas que le soin c'est la
qualité de vie des gens c'est ce que
madame a parlé sénatrice a parlé de
prévention donc il faut aller dans le
territoire il faut s'occuper de là où
vivent les gens du pouvoir
territorialisation 500 g 500 territoire
150000 vous faites une gouverne on s'est
trop vite 500 territoire à peu près 150
mille cent cinquante mille personnes
partagent le même pour tous ok d'accord
le même pour tous d'accord vous vous
allez au delà des ordonnances de 58 les
praticiens hospitaliers peuvent aller en
ville peuvent faire de la ville parce
que les praticiens hospitaliers ont le
même problème qu'en ville c'est que ça
les carrières professionnelles ne sont
plus attirantes se dire que je rentre à
l'hôpital à 25 ans et que j'en sors à 60
ans même hôpital avec une carrière toute
tracée ça n'intéresse plus beaucoup les
jeunes et je suis d'accord mais la
médiatrice que c'est plutôt une bonne
chose donc il faut réinventer leur
métier par rapport à ça vous passez d'un
service public hospitalier c'est-à-dire
qu'on considère qu'il ya que l'hôpital
qui délivre un service public
aujourd'hui 1 410 un service public
territorial de santé vous considérez
qu'il ya le territoire que vous soyez en
ville à l'opie bon je vais pas déroulé
tout ce qu'on va pour donner en quelques
jours mais donc vous voyez que c'est du
fond qu'il faut faire pour pourrait
redonner de l'attractivité
je rappelle que la désertification
médicale c'est aussi une désertification
de service public donc que les
politiques père porte une part de la
responsabilité je suis d'accord qu'il ya
pas que la ruralité mais vous avez des
villes dont paris où ça devient
tellement difficile à vivre que des
médecins qui sont des êtres humains ou
des infirmiers des êtres humains comme
les autres préfèrent aller vivre
ailleurs et paris se désertifie alors ce
qui va pas s'arranger jean-christophe
masseron je reviens vers vous parce que
est-ce qu'on peut dire que ce soit et ce
médecin c'est quand même un moyen de
lutter contre la désertification
oui c'est certain mais la
désertification encore une fois et vous
l'avait bien dit sur sur ce plateau
c'est pas les déserts médicaux n'existe
pas en fait il existe des déserts tout
court et en le problème principal c'est
l'attractivité des territoires et on
peut pas installer des médecins dans un
territoire s'il n'y a pas de service
public s'il n'ya pas du travail pour le
conjoint etc tout ça était bien dit
parra aux intervenants et donc et soyez
ce médecin peut peut être une réponse
à la désertification médicale à
condition que les actes que l'on
dispense soient reconnus à leur juste
valeur nous on s'est toujours engagé à
essayer de détendre notre périmètre
d'action que ce soit en allant au delà
des limites actuelles auprès du patient
ou en activant des services de télé
consultation pour les territoires où
plus reculer ce qui n'est pas la
solution évidemment au miracle mais qui
peut être une des alternatives mais le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui notre
modèle est menacé par à part eux par une
un manque de reconnaissance de la visite
à domicile et ça ça fait un défaut d'un
déficit de recrutement en fait de nous
de nouveaux médecins donc c'est vous
l'avait bien dit tout à l'heure dans ces
temps ces problématiques de l'offre de
soins et de désertification médicale il
ya aussi le problème d'attirer des
jeunes confrères vers la médecine
générale vous l'avez très bien dit
aujourd'hui à une préférence pour le
salariat il faut que vous ayez en tête
aussi que la sociologie des des médecins
s'est transformée à l'instar de
l'ensemble de la transformation de
l'ensemble de la de la société donc
finalement il est difficile pour un
jeune médecin de travailler dans les
mêmes conditions que le que son aîné il
ya 30 ou 40 ans où on pouvait on
accepter des conditions de travail qui
aujourd'hui paraissent complètement
complètement d'un autre temps donc il ya
eu ce changement aussi dans de
transformation de la société un
déclassement aussi de de la profession
de médecin généraliste qui autrefois
avait effectivement un statut
particulier dans la société aujourd'hui
c'est c'est très différent il ya plus ce
prestige de duvet du métier je crois que
là c'est pas une question de vocations
nous dit toujours est-ce qu'il ya
toujours autant de sacerdoce je crois
que le sacerdoce c'est ce qui est
nécessaire pour pour décider de devenir
médecin mais c'est pas le sacerdoce qui
permet d'avoir la juste reconnaissance
il faut il faut autre chose que ça alors
justement là l'image des médecins même
si carraso vous disiez en préparant les
missions vous êtes en surcapacité ça
veut dire quoi que tu as en région
parisienne effectivement ça paraît pas
un désert mais on a une charge de
travail qui s'est beaucoup qui a
beaucoup augmenté au cours de ce serait
cela que des derniers mois avec la crise
sanitaire et c'est vrai que ça devient
difficile à tenir on a beaucoup de
collègues qui sont en burn out on a
énormément de difficultés à continuer
d'accueillir et de gérer les urgences du
quotidien dans nos cabinets parce que on
est débordés
120% de blocage parce que je suis bien
au delà je pense que je suis plutôt à
150 % de mes capacités oui on pousse les
murs on sait plus comment faire
honnêtement c'est fou combien dylan par
jour alors c'est pas de la visite c'est
des consultants des visites par jour moi
j'en fais vraiment oui je pas bon ça
c'est palace ursule temps 30 40 ce qui
pour moi et beaucoup parce que moi je
fais partie d'une génération on nous a
fixé comme objectif de prendre le temps
de ne pas enchaîner deux pas faire deux
visites formant des lieux généralistes
ce qui me concerne oui nous enfin moi je
vois j'ai souvenir de médecins plus âgés
qui faisait la consultation sans rendez
vous avec des salles d'attentes plein de
monde qui attendaient leur tour et qui
passaient du coup j'imagine en cinq
minutes parce que quand on a quarante
personnes dans sa salle d'attenté qu'on
doit partir à une heure donnée mais on
est obligé de faire vite nous on nous a
dit ben non il faut une prise en charge
globale des patients faire de la
prévention faire d'éducation
prendre le temps connaître les patients
gérés avec les autres médecins et les
autres paramédicaux qui sont autour de
la personne donc si on veut faire ça on
peut pas voir 40 personnes par jour ou
alors on finit dans un état
vraiment si on veut voir 40 passant
patients par jour de façon durable
je pense que humainement on s'épuise à
faire ça et c'est pas de la bonne
qualité de soins donc il faut faire les
choses autrement alors il ya aussi cette
histoire de pas vouloir engorger les
urgences il ya eu toute cette histoire
du coc vide qui a fait qu'on a essayé de
moins solliciter l'hôpital de
redistribuer un peu les choses pour
soulager la charge hospitalière donc on
a appris ce relais là la vaccination on
a aussi pris le relais donc on s'est
détaché pour aller dans les centres de
vaccination pour vacciner pour vacciner
dans nos cabinets mais on est toujours
une seule et même personne bloquée à
tout ça qui se rajoute on essaye de
garder la qualité avec plein de missions
supplémentaires
honnêtement je ne vois pas comment c'est
tenable dans le temps qu'il faut qu'on
trouve des solutions et et qu'on est
qu'on fasse évoluer ce modèle là parce
que parce que c'est pas de la bonne
médecine ce qu'on nous demande de faire
c'est exactement ce que ce que je vais
dire allez-y interview c'est de la
mauvaise médecine dont on parle là c'est
assez ça met en colère d'une certaine
façon à les y fait bizarre oui juste
pour le docteur m'a seront moins changé
j'ai pas vu dans les revendications mais
mais je pense réellement que là
la solution passe pas uniquement par la
revalorisation qui est une condition
nécessaire mais pas suffisante hier
qu'il faut réinventer le métier à un
médecin qui fait de la visite à domicile
en tout cas en particulier dans la
nouvelle génération il a probablement
envie de faire un peu d'enseignements un
peu de recherche en tout cas pour
certains et puis d'avoir d'autres
missions que simplement le soin courant
pour lequel il va je reprends les
pathologies chroniques et qui a été
quand même en termes de soins qui est le
le coeur névralgique de de la hausse des
dépenses 80 % des dépenses de santé
viennent de 13 millions de pertes de
france est un qui ont une ou plusieurs
pathologies chroniques là le médecin de
sos médecins ou d'autres organisations
peut parfaitement avoir un rôle
important donc je crois qu'il faut
repenser aussi l'émission pour
revaloriser
ces professions vous pouvez répondre aux
questions pas s'en servir réinventer au
métier est carrément je suis je suis
d'accord je suis d'accord avec ce qui
vient d'être dit d'autant plus qu'on le
fait déjà c'est à dire que nos médecins
sont déjà pour bon nombre d'entre eux
maître de stage on a une commission
scientifique à sos médecins qui permet
aussi d'accompagner des travaux de thèse
et puis comme vous l'avez dit les
médecins aujourd'hui ont envie d'avoir
une carrière multiples de diversifier
leurs activités et sos médecins permet
cette souplesse donc on a su toujours on
a cette agilité pour proposer un métier
riche varié qui permet d'intéresser
d'intéresser bon nombre de médecins
généralistes mais malgré tout il faut
quand même que le modèle économique soit
soit viable et c'est vrai que le tout
paiement à l'acte tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui on peut on peut le contester
mais en tout cas nous a échoué ce
médecin aujourd'hui ce ce pse tout
paiement à l'acte nous posent bien des
soucis
guillotin quand vous vous entendez vous
découvrez pas ça évidemment vous êtes
médecin je le rappelle mais c'est
qu'est-ce que comment vous imaginez là
les prochains mois il ya des
propositions qui vont être faites il ya
peut-être une opportunité historique de
réinventer le système après la crise
sanitaire qu'est ce que vous entendrez
inventé le système on l'a tous dit moi
je suis assez je serais assez pressé de
voir en tout cas vos propositions et on
doit il travailler écouter les
professionnels moi je voulais
réagir sur la désertification médicale
et
parler de la décentralisation je pense
qu'il ya un acte moi je suis convaincu
de d'un acte décentralisation nécessaire
est de faire en sorte que ce soit les
professionnels des territoires avec les
élus qui doivent organiser leur travail
sans rajouter des charges
administratives qui sont chronophages et
qui vont encore manger du temps médical
il faut que les médecins restent au
chevet de leurs patients et les
professionnels paramédicaux mais quand
vous allez si vous voulez attirer un
médecin dans une zone rurale il faut que
cette zone rurale soit attractif donc il
ya aussi tout un travail des
collectivités des collectivités les opci
les régions je conseil régional
parallèlement à ça de la région grand
est les départements on doit se dire que
si un médecin avec sa famille du peu et
si un jour ça m'intéresse d'aller dans
une zone rurale il faut que les poules
épouse trouve quand même de travail à
proximité il faut qu'il ya une école il
faut qu'elle a il faut qu'ils aient de
la mobilité fauqué de la culture il faut
que ce territoire soit organisée
attractif et ça ça peut pas se
déconnecter en fait du débat des de la
désertification médicale on peut pas
laisser des territoires abandonnés et
puis dire au bout de douze années ben
toi le médecin là tu ira là où voilà moi
je pense qu'il faut travailler ensemble
et pour ça il ya une décentralisation
forte et les régions mon avis un rôle à
jouer important donc l'audit le pouvoir
aux régions telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui je dis pas le pouvoir aux
régions je ne vais pas si si je suis pas
si radicale que ça je dis qu'il faut
qu'ils aient une terreur une
territorialisation plus importante une
des pannes déconcentration comme une
décentralisation où on est des marges de
manoeuvre sur les territoires
aujourd'hui on connaît l agence
régionale de santé qui vient en fait
reprend des directives nationales et qui
vient les et parfums dire sur les
territoires ce que le national veut mais
ça c'est pas une de ses passes
décentraliser les choses quoi c'est pas
redonner le pouvoir en fait à la base et
aux soignants c'est ce qu'est ce qui est
très étonnant nous pendant trois ans à
travailler là dessus et pendant un an et
demi sur des conférences de consensus on
avait fait notamment experts dans deux
régions votre prison de région de tous
les partis politiques avec une approche
très transversal sur plan un choix
politique et professionnelle donc il
sait c'est assez stupéfiant devant le
consensus qui assure cette refonte est
globalement le consensus sur le nouveau
modèle font en effet décentralisée
donner aux régions la gestion justement
de la démographie médicale l'état a
montré son incapacité quel que soit le
parti politique au pouvoir pour le gérer
on a confié la gestion du paramédical
aux régions confions la gestion mais de
la démographie médicale confions ces
territoires de santé aujourd'hui à dc
pts que pour l'aimer pour la ville il ya
des j'ai acheté pour pour le saut il ya
d'abc catry des secteurs de psychiatrie
mais enfin quand on crée les territoires
c'est quand même pour les citoyens c'est
pas lui il n'y a pas un citoyen en
france qui se dit connaît son j'ai
acheté son cpts fait tout ça mais déjà
c'est une usine à gaz pour les soignants
pour donc la plupart ont abandonné toute
action là dedans tellement il vaut
accession perte de temps les j'ai acheté
c'est un machin pu revenir serait
d'ailleurs j'ai un groupement
hospitalier territoire terre qu'on a dit
on va gérer les hôpitaux d'endetter à
l'échelon des territoires comme si on
connaît en disant je en va des convois
d'aidé consenti pour moi si vous êtes à
l'heure la décision alors est prise
d'une part on ne fait que des concentrés
et pas décentraliser la différence est
qu'en fait c'est toujours l'état mais
vous mettez proche des territoires et
vous voyez que après la crise on n'a
fait qu'aggraver la xoom ce qu'est ce
qu'on a pris le seul mesures
structurelles au delà des de
l'investissement supplémentaire qu'on a
fait c'est de donner plus de pouvoirs à
la rs au département en disant on va
renforcer la rs dans le département mais
c'est qu'on se dit ni un peut-être qu'en
fait on n'a pas suffisamment investi sur
la technostructure on va la rapprocher
du territoire évidemment on va aggraver
le problème puisque on a un état qui se
retrouve encore plus près du terrain des
acteurs et donc plus en conflit avec lui
donc voilà il ya un vrai consensus sur
le nouveau modèle mais il faut une
volonté politique en tout cas il faut
déjà le l'expliqué ce qu'on va faire
dans quelques jours merci beaucoup merci
à tous d'avoir participé à ce débat
c'était passionnant c'était édifiant